so Jeffrey Epstein the alleged sex
trafficker who was accused of course
along with Donald Trump of raping a 13
year old girl was found dead in his jail
cell of what's being called an apparent
suicide and of course the conspiracy
theories surrounding his death
predictably and just instantly exploding
disclaimer once again this story and all
of the ones related to it or last week's
shootings and all of this stuff will be
fully to monetize by YouTube as they
have been for the entire week consider
supporting the work we do directly
because YouTube has determined that all
of these stories are not ad or brand
safe Epstein was arrested and awaiting
trial on charges of sexually abusing
dozens of young girls Epstein had been
put on suicide watch after being found
with what seemed to be a self-inflicted
wound
then was taken off of suicide watch 12
days before he was found hanged in his
cell why he was taken off of suicide
watch is currently unclear that's
becoming part of the conspiracies
surrounding the conspiracy theories
surrounding this and I mean we have to
start sort of unpacking it with the
logic of the conspiracist one of the
ideas is he was taking off of suicide
watch so that he would kill himself
or it wasn't really suicide he was taken
off of suicide watch to create a cover
for someone to murder him and then for
it to be called a suicide because hey he
was taken off of suicide watch anyway
one way or the other immediately a whole
bunch of elected officials want an
investigation this includes senators
this includes Donald Trump's Attorney
General William bar and others and of
course Trump's Justice Department being
the department that will now carry
forward whatever investigation is going
to take place is extraordinarily
problematic according to many because of
the connections between Epstein and
Trump in and of themselves now I have to
tell you the main conspiracy sort of
doesn't make that much sense in terms of
motive given that it is much more
complex
than the simplest murder hypothesis that
exists or let me put it a different way
the idea is Epstein was about to pull
Trump into the mess documents might show
that Epstein was recruiting young girls
at mar-a-lago or there might have been
something revealed related to the girl
that Epstein allegedly raped who was
also allegedly raped by Donald Trump
when she was 13 years old at the
Manhattan condo of Jeffrey Epstein so
the idea is let's silence him let's
arrange for him to be killed
but step back for just one second
believed child abusers are not treated
well in prisons and jails they are some
of the primary targets of violence
outside of gang-related violence in
jails and prisons if you want to go in
the direction of this wasn't suicide
it was murder which by the way I'm open
to I'm not dismissing this by any means
you don't actually need to go - it was a
political murder involving Trump or
whoever else child sex abusers are
targeted in the prison system and it
requires far fewer explanations and
assumptions other than why was he taken
off of suicide watch if indeed that is
part of the entire circumstance now of
course immediately people are coming up
with conspiracy theories that make no
sense for me if you say imagine this
wasn't a suicide and it was a murder who
is most likely to have done it let's
explore that I've already said if you
look at a history of how this works in
prisons people in the prison system who
go after child molesters would be like
the number one a culprits in my mind
second it would be something related to
trump or merrill ago because of those
connections but right wingers heard
about this apparent suicide
and immediately said oh it's related to
Dems or Hillary or something related the
pizza gate or Bill Clinton was once in a
picture with Jeffrey Epstein this is
another Clinton body count person or
whatever Epstein was super rich everyone
in power knew him pictured with Bill
Clinton pictured in many pictures with
Donald Trump but we have specific
allegations that Donald Trump raped a
girl that Epstein also raped
Epstein's manhattan condo if we are
simply theorizing I have no idea why you
go to the Clintons before you go to
Trump
not to mention Trump has a long history
of sexualizing his own daughter
he's on video with Epstein evaluating
the attractiveness of girls at a party
and by the way if Bill Clinton or the
Clintons in general are so powerful as
these conspiracy theories require them
or imply them to be why weren't they
able to just manipulate things and get
Hillary Clinton elected that is not one
that they will often answer one idea
that's been floated is Epstein staged
the first suicide attempt in other words
the first suicide attempt was not really
a suicide attempt it was Epstein knowing
that he was potentially in danger doing
something to get himself put on suicide
watch and that that wasn't enough that's
another idea genuinely I have no idea
what happened but I was not shocked when
over the weekend I heard that he was
found dead in his cell I want to hear
from you what do you think happened here
let me know and ideally maybe try to
support it with some evidence as well